my uncle gave me this old dried out cob
of corn about eight years ago and I've
just had it around as decoration but I
got a bit hungry today and of the six
main types of corn this cob happens to
be popcorn that means its whole is
really strong so when I warm it up all
the moisture in the endosperm doesn't
just turn to steam and gradually Escape
oh no pressure can build and that
pressure builds to about 135 PSI at
which point the hole bursts and the
starches and proteins in the endosperm
turn into that beautiful foam that we
call popped popcorn now as you can see
this is a huge mess really you should do
this by putting the cob in a paper bag
or something but I didn't have any paper
bags and also my mom lives hundreds of
miles away and does not even know I'm
doing this here are the results I call
it popcorn on the cob as you can see
though most of the kernels popped off
the cob but it's delicious
and here's a fun fact
fruit